[Music]
[Applause]
kanye west
levitates right on out of the stadium
during the second
donda listening party where kim
kardashian was
in attendance to support her estranged
husband him and i have been best friends
for a really long time and just been in
each other's lives the grammy winner
held his second large-scale listening
event for his upcoming album
donda on thursday and it didn't
disappoint
[Music]
at his first listening party held on
july 22nd
fans said the artist essentially just
vibed out to his
own music in the middle of the
mercedes-benz stadium in atlanta georgia
in front of a sold out crowd of
thousands
i mean it was just fun to go on and just
do something for my heart
two weeks later after delaying the
release of the album
and actually living at the stadium in a
small room the whole time
kanye brought the theatrics for
listening party number
[Music]
this is two it goes
that's the stronger rapper in the middle
of the huge stadium
with a small mattress and blanket as his
music plays over the loudspeakers
[Music]
on stage kanye did push-ups danced to
his songs
made some phone calls paced around and
even took a nap
fans also noticed that kanye's attire
for listening party number two
was way different than his attire for
listening party number one
the musician traded that red jacket and
beige mask for an all-black ensemble
including a black vest with danda
written on it
and a black mask but the highlight of
the night came at the end
when kanye straight up levitated
with the help of some wires and dramatic
lighting
[Music]
[Applause]
and you know who loved it his estranged
wife
kim kardashian we have to thank kim the
40 year old reality star took to her
insta story to share the show-stopping
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
moment
[Applause]
[Music]
the mama 4 also posted this pic of a
black glove and balenciaga full face
mask
similar to the ones the 44 year old
rapper has been sporting in recent weeks
as well as this snap inside the stadium
kim also attended her ex's first donda
listening party with her sister khloe
kardashian her pal jonathan cheban
and her and kanye's four children
eight-year-old north
five-year-old saint three-year-old
chicago and two-year-old
psalm
a source tells et that the two quote
have been supportive of each other since
kim filed for divorce in february
adding quote kanye and her have been
co-parenting successfully and both of
them want what's best for the kids
and while donda still hasn't been
released for purchase or streaming
kanye did announce that the yeezy gap
red round jacket that he wore at his
first listening event
is now available for pre-order for two
hundred dollars
[Music]